DAN HERMES: Hey, everyone.
I'm Dan Hermes.
You can't see my
face just yet--
I have a document that I
want everyone to see--
but I am on the Google
Commerce team here in
Developer Relations at Google,
and we're here to talk about
the Content API for Shopping.
I have two announcements to
make, and then one question
that I'd actually like to
discuss with Andrew Lamonica,
who's in the Hangout with me.
And also Caroline, if she has
any inputs yet, but I don't
know that she will.
And let's get started.
So this first thing I want to
announce, this document I
have, something that the
community has been asking for
for a long time, and certainly
a lot in the last few months.
And that's a developer's
guide for using
the .NET Client library.
I just published it yesterday
afternoon.
It can be found at
developers.googl
e.com/shopping-c
ontent/developersguide.net.
And if you don't want to
memorize that, you can just go
to developers.google.com, search
for the Content API,
and then in the Developer
Resources section in our left
nav on our Content API docs,
you can find the .NET
developer's guide.
And this guide will tell you
pretty much anything you want
to do with your items feed with
the .NET client library.
So inserting, updating, deleting
individual items, and
getting individual items, as
well as making batch requests,
sending and requesting
performance data, handling
errors, handling batch errors,
and even using the generic
projection instead of the
schema projection.
As well as warnings in dry run
mode, which are a big thing
when you're just testing and
getting things implemented.
So please check it
out if you are a
.NET programmer, developer.
It was a lot of hard work by
me, and also the document
brought about a lot of new
features for the library
itself, which was pretty nice.
So as you try to document
something, and it doesn't
exist, then you go about
implementing it.
So, now for my face.
Hi, everybody.
The second announcement I want
to make, since we last met,
the sessions for Google I/O
have been released.
So we'll be giving two different
talks on the first
day of Google I/O, which is
June 27, and the tentative
schedule is at--
let me find it-- it's
at developers.googl
e.com/events/io/sessions.
And we're going to first have
a remedial introductory
session and talk about how to
improve data quality and how
to go about making sure that
errors don't continue to
happen, and things like that.
And then we're going to have a
more in-depth discussion about
using local shopping and having
products with the local
channel rather than the
online channel.
So those are my two
announcements.
Now that I've done talking for
five straight minutes, I do
have a question before you
guys have any questions.
And from the consensus before,
with this shortened Memorial
Day week, there may not be any
questions other than mine.
Which I'm OK with.
We'll just have a shorter
Hangout this week than we've
had in the previous weeks
So the question is--
and the reason I'm going to ask
it specifically to Andrew
is because I know he's used
the API Dashboard in the
Merchant Center.
And just a quick review for
people who haven't used it,
the API Dashboard is a way to
view your errors through your
account, through the
Merchant Center.
And then also recently, we added
a feature that allows
you to go in and edit the
request that resulted in an
error, and try to resend it in
dry run mode, and find out if
you fixed the error or if
the error's still there.
So it's a nice summary of the
errors you have if for some
reason your logs aren't
comprehensive enough, or some
other reason.
So with that said, one limiting
feature of this API
Dashboard is that you can only
see errors for an account
associated with an authenticated
user.
The implications of this are
if you're using an MCA, a
Multi-Client Account, and you
are authenticated as the owner
of the MCA, then all your errors
that you make on behalf
of all your sub-accounts will
not actually show in the API
Dashboard for those
sub-accounts.
Rather, it'll show up in the
API Dashboard for the MCA
account because that's the
account directly associated
with the authenticated
user, right?
So there are a few paths that
we're considering taking, and
I wanted to hear your feedback,
Andrew, on what
would be helpful for you in what
you've seen with the API
Dashboard so far.
And what you think you could use
and what you think really
wouldn't be helpful.
So I'll read them off one by
one, and you can comment one
by one, if you want.
Or you can tell me
just to go on.
So the first would be seeing
errors in a sub-account
regardless of who the
authenticated user was.
So that would be errors either
made from the parent or from
an administrator for
that sub-account.
So it would be sort of a
mix of different users.
I'm assuming most accounts that
are managed by MCAs don't
have more than one authenticated
account making
requests [INAUDIBLE],
but it's possible.
So what are your thoughts
on that?
ANDREW LAMONICA: Well, for me,
it doesn't really matter.
Because I have the same code
running, sending all the
requests, so it's actually good
for me to have it all
rolled up into one.
I can see if there's a problem
across all the--
DAN HERMES: So that
won't go away.
ANDREW LAMONICA: [INAUDIBLE]
--code.
I can see where some people
who might have different
authenticated users, that
may be useful to them.
Although I think even probably
most of the MCAs are going to
be running the same code
for all of their--
DAN HERMES: Right.
So I acknowledge that.
We acknowledge that.
So the thought would not be
that getting to see a
different sub-account would be
able to help you analyze a
different set of code
that's running.
Rather, maybe there's something
wrong with the
settings for that account or
something like that, and you
have a specific sub-account
where you're having issues.
Right now, through your MCA,
you can't filter by
sub-account, and that's sort
of the goal there.
The other one is more of a
secondary thing, that being
that you could see requests
across all
authenticated users.
The reason I mentioned it at all
is just because it could
throw you off if you did have
another authenticated user.
OK.
So it sounds like not that
useful to you, but you think
it might be useful for others.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah.
Maybe people that have varying
degrees of data quality.
I've knocked out most of the
data quality error messages
that come up in there, but I
could see if people have data
coming from different sources,
they might want to know if one
sub-account was responsible
for most of their
data quality errors.
That could be a useful
statistic.
DAN HERMES: Caroline, do you
have any thoughts on that?
Looks like she's either
not paying attention
or not miced up.
That's OK.
So, the other one is really
similar to this one, except it
would be a filter within the MCA
View or some similar thing
to this, where you can see
requests that you made
directly from your authenticated
account, but
filter based on sub-account.
So, we don't really need
to discuss it.
We pretty much discussed that
sort of functionality.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Caroline's
in the chat, by the way.
DAN HERMES: Oh, she is?
I see that now.
"Sorry, mic's not working.
Busted my headset yesterday."
That's OK.
So another one would be--
let me see.
So this first option that I
brought up about being able to
see errors for a specific
sub-account irrespective of
the authenticated user, the
other one would just be an
extension of that, where you
could create filter groups.
So either this sub-account, or
this sub-account, or this
sub-account.
If you had, let's say, all your
Canadian accounts or--
that's a bad example, because
Canada's not supported there.
But all your US accounts, or
all your Great Britain
accounts, or something
like this.
What do you think about
something like that, in
comparison?
Do you think that's something
you could use
or you would use?
ANDREW LAMONICA: I'm not the
right one to ask, because it's
functionally equivalent for
me, because we pretty much
have one account per country.
DAN HERMES: Cool.
Oh, that's right.
Well, you guys don't do
sub-accounts based on seller?
ANDREW LAMONICA: No.
We talked about doing that at
one point, and I think there
was an issue with too many
sellers, and they didn't want
to mix both, like a
rollup account and
individual seller accounts.
I mean, we would definitely be
open to going by seller, but
we have a lot of sellers.
DAN HERMES: So it sounds like
you guys already considered
the common case, but the
common case for other
marketplaces that do that is,
let's say they have a quota of
x sub-accounts in a certain
country, right?
Then they have x minus 1
sub-accounts, and then their
last sub-account is just a
spillover for smaller sellers.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Yeah.
That's something--
I think I talked to Ari about
that, maybe, a while back.
And I can't remember
what the--
there was some reason that that
wasn't good for everybody
at that time.
But we would definitely be open
to looking at that again.
It would certainly help narrow
down quality issues.
Right now, I just kind of, like,
I have some code to kind
of keeps an eye on sellers that
have too many quality
issues and just doesn't
send them anymore.
But that would be easier if
they have a sub-account.
It would just be like, no
more for those guys.
DAN HERMES: Exactly.
So Caroline, what he's
mentioning as you're
considering your move to MCA,
having multiple sellers coming
through the same account can be
an issue in that one of the
seller's data quality issues
can spoil the party for
everyone else.
So if you're able to saddle them
in their own sub-account,
then those issues only affect
that sub-account rather than
the entire country account
in the case of Andrew.
CAROLINE: Well, if we are
doing separate merchant
accounts-- you can hear
me now, right?
DAN HERMES: Yep.
CAROLINE: OK.
So if we were getting separate
merchant accounts and client
authentication versus OAuth,
that would be irrelevant.
DAN HERMES: Yeah.
Authentication's irrelevant,
whether using--
CAROLINE: All our merchants
have separate accounts,
anyway, so I don't think
that's an issue.
DAN HERMES: Yes.
I was just saying in the MCA
case, that would be something
to consider.
CAROLINE: They denied me, so I
was hoping you were going to
look into that.
Did you see that?
I sent it along to you?
DAN HERMES: What's that?
CAROLINE: They denied the MCA
account, and I sent that to
you last week?
DAN HERMES: It got reapproved.
We can take this off the
Hangout, because I did have
some other questions
for you about that.
CAROLINE: OK, cool.
DAN HERMES: Yeah, there was some
miscommunication there.
CAROLINE: It took me a couple
days, because I was concerned
about which email address
we had signed up with.
So it's probable that
the couple of days
lag didn't help things.
DAN HERMES: Yeah, let's connect
after this Hangout.
I think I'm just going to end
early if you guys don't have
anymore questions.
Any questions?
ANDREW LAMONICA: I'm reading
your Google I/O
summaries right now.
That'll be pretty cool.
DAN HERMES: Yeah, it
should be cool.
We got some cool demos prepared,
and the first talk,
Andrew, you may be a
little bored in.
But the second one is definitely
going to be a lot
of brand spanking new stuff.
I'll be speaking in the first
one that you might consider
going, but I try not to be a
boring speaker, so we'll see
what happens.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Well, you can
always give away some cool
stuff or something.
DAN HERMES: Sure, sure.
CAROLINE: [? He's always ?]
asking for swag.
I can't believe this.
Unabashedly asking for
swag all the time.
DAN HERMES: Oh, it's common
practice from our communities.
ANDREW LAMONICA: Just remember
to link to those from the
email list when they get
posted on YouTube.
It's kind of hard to find
the Google I/O videos.
I don't know if I'm just bad
at searching or something.
DAN HERMES: I'll probably start
having a dedicated page
in the documentation to videos
and presentations
and things like that.
We actually have a Google
Shopping Channel now on the
Google Developer's Live YouTube
account, and I can
post that to the forum.
The demo tool is now hosted on a
separate app engine instance
from developers.google.com, and
I've started putting slide
decks in that instance
as well.
So there's a lot of good
resources from the talks and
the presentations we give that
can be pulled into one easy to
navigate place.
Well, guys, it was nice
talking to you.
I hope you've enjoyed your
three day weekend.
And one last announcement, which
I will also make via the
forum and via Google+.
We're going to move Tuesdays.
This Hangout is part of a
larger effort by all of
Developer Relations at Google,
and I picked Wednesdays
because it was the middle
of the week, and no
other reason at all.
It wasn't more convenient
for me, wasn't less
convenient for me.
It was just far from Monday and
far from Friday, you know?
So we're going to move to
Tuesdays because of this big
pileup of some of the other
teams. And so, the next one
will be, instead of in 14 days,
it will be in 13 days,
which is June--
I don't know--
let me look.
June 5.
So that's actually the day
before my one year
anniversary at Google.
So June 5, I will see you guys,
and we will likely have
somebody from Ads and AdWords
with us as a guest. So I did
take into consideration some
of the suggestions you had
last time, Andrew, when we met
on May 16, and have gotten
some interest from some PMs
and some folks in AdWords,
some folks in Ops.
And so our first guest next
time, June 5, will likely be
one of the folks from Ads.
All right?
ANDREW LAMONICA: Sweet.
DAN HERMES: All right.
See you guys.
Have a good one.
ANDREW LAMONICA: See you.
CAROLINE: See you.
Thank you.
DAN HERMES: Sure.